Guten Abend.
Ich heiße Hamidi, ich bin Assistenz aus dieser Station.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmengespräch durchführen.
Sind Sie einverstanden?
Oh ja, guten Abend Herr Doktor.
Guten Abend, verstehen Sie mich auch Doktor?
Mein Name ist Mohammed Hamidi.
Hamidi, das ist aber ein komischer Name.
Woher kommt dieser Name?
Ja, das ist eine arabische Name.
Eine arabische Name?
Als Syrien kommt es.
Ach so, das ist ja sehr traurig.
Sie haben Krieg bei Ihnen im Land.
Ja, genau. Leider.
Schön, dass Sie da sind.
Ja.
Zuerst stelle ich ein paar allgemeine Fragen.
Und dann kommen wir zu Ihren aktuellen Beschwerden.
Ist das in Ordnung?
Nein, nein, nein.
Ich kann nicht lange warten.
Ich habe starke Schmerzen.
Wo sind Sie die Schmerzen?
Das ist hier auf der rechten Seite vom Bauch.
Das fängt an der Flanke an.
Das zieht mir ein bisschen den Unterbauch.
Seit 1-2 Stunden, das ist ein ganz schlimmer Moment.
Okay, konnten Sie ein bisschen einige Minuten aushalten,
die Schmerzen?
Oder sollte ich Ihnen Schmerzmittel geben?
Vielleicht ganz kurz, aber man sollte schon relativ schnell
Schmerzmedikamente geben.
Deswegen bin ich auch gekommen.
Ganz schnell.
Okay.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Julia.
Julia.
Bauer.
Okay, Frau Julia, wie alt sind Sie?
Mein Nachname ist Bauer.
Julia ist mein Vorname.
Ich bin 52 Jahre alt.
52?
Ja.
Und wann genau sind Sie geboren?
14. Juli 1970.
Und wie viel grossen Sie?
Groß.
62.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich wiege ungefähr 65 Kilo.
Okay, Frau Bauer, was führt Sie zu uns?
Also, wie schon gesagt, ich habe seit circa 2 Stunden
sehr heftige, starke Schmerzen im rechten Oberbau.
Und das ist manchmal richtig kolikartig und wellenartig.
Ganz, ganz stark.
Okay, Frau Bauer, ich mache eine sehr kurze Kurbe-Schöntursuchung
für meine Diagnose.
Und dann gebe ich Ihnen einen speziellen Schmerzmittel.
Oh ja, bitte, bitte, das ist ganz, ganz schlimm.
Ich würde Ihnen das zu einem Nennesgespräch.
Das wäre sehr nett.
Vielen Dank.
Okay, Frau Bauer, Sie haben sehr starke Schmerzen im Oberbau.
Und was ich möchte wissen, ich habe schon bemerkt.
Und wir können, wenn Sie voll gut,
wir können die Annesgespräche dauern.
Im Moment wird es wieder ein bisschen besser.
Ja, okay, dann wir kommen zu Ihren aktuellen Beschwerden.
Seit, Sie haben gesagt, seit 2 Stunden,
sind die Schmerzen plötzlich oder langsam aufgetreten?
Relativ schnell, sind sie aufgetreten.
Strahlen die Schmerzen irgendwo hin?
Ja, wie gesagt, in den Bauch, also in die Mitte vom Bauch
und in die Leiste.
Leiste.
Okay, auf der Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10.
Wie sind Ihre Schmerzen?
Vorbei, Ihr Einste sehr leichte Schmerzen
und 10 sehr starke.
Ich würde schon sagen, 8 bis 9 waren die vorhin.
Jetzt ist es wieder ein bisschen besser, aber sehr, sehr stark.
Okay, haben Sie etwas gegen die Schmerzen angenommen?
Ich hatte leider zu Hause keine Medikamente,
deswegen bin ich sofort hergekommen.
Okay.
Frau Bauer, haben Sie ähnliche Beschwerden?
Nein, das ist das 1. Mal.
Ich hatte so viele Schmerzen noch nie gehabt.
Sie haben gesagt, Rüste über Bauch ohne Ausstrahlung,
oder mit Ausstrahlung bis Rüste Leiste?
Genau.
Andere Beschwerden, haben Sie?
Ja, so eine leichte Übelkeit habe ich noch.
Auch seit 2 Stunden?
Das ist erst jetzt seit 1,5 Stunden, kam später.
Hatten Sie Urbrüchen oder nur Urbelkeit?
Nein, das ist nur eine Übelkeit.
Haben Sie Probleme mit Wasserlössern oder Stundern?
Ich habe immer wieder so einen gewissen Haarendrank,
aber es kam nur ganz wenig Urin.
Sie haben gesagt, dass es bei Haaren Drang bränen kann?
Ja, ich habe nur einen Haarendrank.
Ich muss öfters auf Toilette, aber ich habe kein Bränen.
Und weniger kommt?
Ja, es kommt ganz wenig Urin.
Haben Sie bemerkt, ob die Farbe des Urins verändert ist?
Nein, da ist nichts Auffälliges.
Könnt ihr mir sagen, ob es bestimmte Auslöse gibt?
Nein, das ist ganz plötzlich gekommen, ich weiß es nicht.
Ich habe nichts Besonderes gemacht.
Nicht nach dem Essen oder Bewegung?
Nein, ich habe nichts Besonderes gemacht.
Gibt es etwas, die Schmerzen verändert oder verstärkt sich?
Es ist jetzt zwei Stunden, da kann ich nicht sagen.
Die Schmerzen kommen, werden sehr stark, lassen ein bisschen nach,
aber sind relativ schnell wieder zunehmend.
Auch jetzt wird wieder zunehmend.
Jetzt werden die Schmerzen wieder etwas stärker.
Haben Sie Probleme mit Atemnot?
Nein, da habe ich jetzt keine.
Herzprobleme?
Nein.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Ich habe mich jetzt nicht aufgefallen, aber für habe ich jetzt nicht.
Nein, und Schöttelwurst?
Bitte?
Schöttelwurst.
Ich habe Ihre letzte Frage leider nicht verstanden.
Haben Sie Obelkeit oder haben Sie gesagt, Sie haben Obel?
Ja, Übelkeit habe ich, ja.
Haben Sie Nachtschweiß oder vermehrte Schwitzen?
Nein.
Meine Frage, Sie haben nicht verstanden, Schöttelwurst, haben Sie Schöttelwurst?
Ach so, nein, nein, Schöttelwurst habe ich nicht.
Okay, Herr Frau Bauer, leiden Sie an chronischen Krankungen
oder hatten Sie vor Krankungen zum Beispiel Bluthochdruck, Zuckerkrankheit, Rose?
Ich hatte bis jetzt keine Probleme, war alles in Ordnung,
ich habe auch keine Medikamente genommen, ich war eigentlich nie richtig krank.
Wollt Ihr schon einmal Obel?
Ich habe mal vor zehn Jahren am linken Knie eine kleine OP gehabt, eine Artroskopie,
aber sonst hatte ich keine OP.
Linken Knie?
Welche Operationen?
Ja, ich glaube, da war an den Kreuzband dann etwas gerissen und dann haben wir nachgeschaut.
Band?
Kreuzband, ja.
Okay, Sie haben gesagt, Sie nehmen keine Medikamente ein, ja?
Nein.
Haben Sie Allergien gegraben?
Unverträglichkeit?
Ja, ich habe eine Laktose und Verträglichkeit, aber ansonsten, das ist aber nicht so schlimm.
Okay. Frau Bauer, rauchen Sie?
Nein.
Brinken Sie Alkohol?
Ach, sehr, sehr selten.
Was meinen Sie selten?
Zum Beispiel Provochel wie viel und was für eine?
Nein, nein, nein, also vielleicht ein bis zwei Mal im Jahr.
Nur an zwei.
Ungefähr Sie brinken nicht.
Nein, nein, nein.
Gut.
Frau Bauer, nehmen Sie bitte diese Frage nicht befördlich.
Nehmen Sie Brocken?
Brocken?
Ja.
Ich habe mal als Studentin ab und zu mal was probiert, aber ich nehme keine Brocken.
Nur einmal.
Ja.
Was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich bin Schneiderin, Modedesignerin.
Schneiderin.
Sind Sie für die Errate?
Ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe einen Sohn.
Ist er gesund?
Ja, er ist gesund.
Nehmen Sie zusammen mit Ihrer Familie?
Ja, ich lebe mit meinem Mann und meinem Sohn zusammen.
Frau Bauer, leiden Ihre Eltern an chronische Erkrankungen?
Mein Vater hat einen hohen Blutdruck und Diabetes, aber das ist glaube ich ganz gut eingestellt.
Da verwarte ich Medikamente.
Medikamente?
Doch, hat Medikamente.
Ah, okay.
Und meine Mutter, der geht eigentlich gut, hat keine Medikamente.
Gesund?
Ja.
Gut.
Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe noch eine Schwester.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, eigentlich nicht so.
Sie hat ein paar Erkrankungen, aber sie wartet auf ein Ergebnis.
Man vermutet, sie hat einen Kloten auf dem Brust.
Da wartet man jetzt auf das Ergebnis, ob das etwas Bösartiges ist.
Ein Knott in dem Brust?
Ja.
Okay.
Wirst du da links sagen?
Das weiß ich jetzt.
Ich glaube auf der linken Seite, hat sie gesagt, ich weiß es nicht.
Okay.
Frau Bauer, sind Sie geimpft gegen Kinderkrankungen und Corona?
Ja, meine Impfungen sind komplett, also mein Hausarzt kontrolliert die immer regelmäßig.
Da habe ich keine Probleme.
Und letzte Frage, was für die Zirkus monetische Blutung ist regelmäßig?
Also ich habe seit 4, 5 Jahren in der Medopause, ich habe keinen Zirkus.
Seit 5, 6 Jahren.
Okay.
Noch eine Frage, ist Ihre Gewicht verändert in der letzten Zeit?
Nein, das war immer gleich.
Okay, Frau Bauer, ich habe die wichtige Frage gestellt.
Haben Sie eine Frage angestellt oder mussten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Vielen Dank.
Ich glaube, ich brauche wieder ein bisschen Schmerzen mit die Kamerend.
Die Schmerzen nehmen wieder zu.
Können Sie mir noch mal ein bisschen Schmerzinfusionen geben?
Ja, wir geben Ihnen Schmerzmittel, aber wenn es möglich, ein bisschen aushalten,
für einige Minuten.
Okay, aber bitte beeinsichtlich, das wird immer schlimmer.
Ja, sehr schnell, wir machen Korbischöder Suchung,
weil manchmal die Schmerzen helfen uns vor bestimmte Diagnosestellen.
Ja, aber das ist schon starker Schmerz, bitte tun Sie etwas dagegen.
Ja, ich verstehe Ihre Sorgen, nur 2, 3 Minuten.
Okay, bitte beeinsichtlich.
Ja, Kollegen habe ich.
Haben die Kollegen noch Fragen? Das war heute schon viel besser, Dr. Mahmood.
Dr. Mahmood, sehr gut.
Wenn keine Fragen sind, dann machen wir gleich die Übergabe an den Oberarzt.
Ja, okay.
In letzter Zeit, Stuhlgang erhalten, wir müssen fragen.
War alles in Ordnung.
Ja, keine Probleme.
Aber ich glaube, er hat gefragt.
Was hat es denn so gemacht?
Und, Könnensee, die Schmerzen, Generalbeschreibung,
sind Sie ja dumf, stechen, brennend?
Er hat gesagt, er hat...
Nein, nicht Kolikartik.
Wir haben uns nicht beschreiben.
Noch genauer, das beschreiben?
Ja, genau, beschreiben.
Wie soll ich sagen, Kolikartik, wellenartik, eher dumpf?
Wenn der Patient sagt Kolikartik, das ist nicht Beschreibung.
Oder muss ich weiter fragen?
Kolikartik bedeutet das dauerhaft.
Aber dumpf ist die Schmerzen, Generalbeschreibung beschrieben.
Beschreibte Schmerzen genauer.
Okay.
Aber gut, in der Klinik reicht das, wenn man sagt, Kolikartik,
dann weiß man, dass es meistens auch dumpfe Schmerzen sind,
weil es meistens Kolikartik, wellenartik ist meistens im Bauch.
Gut, das kann man nochmal genauer beschreiben, falsch ist es nicht.
Gut, wenn keine anderen Fragen da sind, dann machen wir die Übergabe
an den Oberarzt.
Okay, guten Abend, Herr Oberarzt.
Ja, guten Abend, Herr Doktor, wie geht es Ihnen?
Danke, ich würde Ihnen gerne die neuen Patienten vorstellen.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Aber natürlich, bitte schön, was haben Sie denn aufgenommen?
Ihr Name, Julia Bauer, sie ist 52 Jahre alt und zwar geboren am 14. Juli 1970.
Sie ist 1,63 m groß und wiegt 65 kg.
Okay.
Die Patientin hat bei uns heute, nachmittag, wegen sehr starken,
häufig bestehenden, kolikartigen Schmerzen in dem Rösteflanke,
mit Strahlung nach Rüsteleiste vorgestellt.
Mit Ausstrahlung in die rechte Leiste.
Rüsteleiste vorgestellt.
Okay.
Die Patienten berüstete, dass die Schmerzen plötzlich aufgetreten sind,
die Schmerzintensität entspricht 8% auf der Schmerzskala.
Ja.
Dagegen hätte sie kein Medikament ein.
Eingenommen.
Diese Schmerzen hatte sie als erste Mal.
Sie hatte ähnliche Beschwerden.
Ich hatte keine ähnlichen Beschwerden.
Die Patienten klagten auch über Obelkeit und Dysphorie.
Die Frage nach Ausloser wurde verneint.
Die Frage nach Verkrankungen und Medikamenteneinnahmen.
Ich habe eine kleine Operation in dem Rücken durchgeführt.
Die Frage nach allergien wurde verneint.
Die Patientin leide ein Laktose in Toleranz.
Sehr selten bringt Alkohol.
Die Frage nach Konsum wurde verneint.
Sie hat nur einmal als Student wahr eingenommen oder probiert.
Die Patientin hat eine Schwester, die mit Brustknot oder Not hat.
Frau Bauer ist Schneiderin.
Sie ist für den Hybride und hat einen gesunden Sohn.
Die Umfestertes ist vollständig.
Das war auf meiner Seite.
Vielen Dank.
Die Diagnose ist eine akute Kohlolitis.
Sie haben eine Diagnose.
Heute war es viel besser als beim letzten Mal.